des centaines de personnes ont déferlé
dans les rues de paris car une marque
donner des vêtements gratuitement on te
résume ce qu'il s'est passé en fait
c'est la marque revenge ex qui est à
l'origine de l'événement la marque s'est
créé il ya quelques mois et n'avait
encore jamais vendu de vêtements pour se
faire connaître elle a décidé de donner
gratuitement une centaine de vêtements
pull gasquet est suivi par quelques
milliers de personnes la marque demande
aux gens de ramener un max de monde
pensons que 50 à 100 personnes maximum
viendront prévu à 19 heures le 24 août
au jardin des tuileries à paris
l'événement rassemble des dizaines de
personnes dès la fin de matinée en fin
d'après midi ils sont des centaines et
les organisateurs craignent que la
situation dégénère s'ils viennent
distribuer leurs vêtements aux tuileries
la marque décale alors l'événement à la
place vendôme 300 mètres plus long des
centaines de personnes arrivent alors
rapidement et le stock de vêtements par
en quelques secondes des vols et des
violences auraient été commis durant
l'hiver d'après la marque déplore ces
actes et regrette de ne pas avoir assez
organisé son premier event le prochain
événement sera mieux organisée et plus
sécurisé assure-t-elle